le sport est bénéfique pour la santé
mais à quel point elle l'activité
physique peut-elle avoir une influence
sur les jeunes et en particulier les
adolescents
une étude grandeur nature montre de
façon indiscutable les bienfaits du
sport reportage à strasbourg lors emmené
chantier à pasteur est vite fait c'est
lorsque je suis à se toucher
c'est la ballade me touchent directement
sans qu'elle ait touché le sol avant je
m'assois en apparence il s'agit d'un
cours d'éducation physique très
ordinaire avec des collégiens aussi très
ordinaire mais de la différence de leurs
petits camarades
ces élèves d'alsaciens font davantage de
sport cinq heures en moyenne par semaine
trois heures obligatoires et 2h
facultatif dans les heures d'activités
la femme de ps il ya une évaluation ya
des contrats alors que dans nos
activités alyzia pas de contrainte et on
vient s'amuser et on essaie d'en montrer
fair voyez on serait pas forcément un
sport traditionnel des jeux
ce dispositif s'inscrit dans le cadre
d'une étude menée par l'institut pasteur
de strasbourg mille collégiens du bas
rhin ont été tirés au sort pour la
moitié d'entre eux l'activité physique
ne change pas les 500 autres collégiens
dont ceux ci sont encouragés à faire du
sport un an après sa mise en place
d'études de livre ses premiers résultats
nous avons montré ça c'est assez
original chez l'enfant ça n'avait pas
été montré dans la population générale
que l'activité physique un effet
favorable sur la pression artérielle sur
le cholestérol mais également sur
l'insuline par exemple qui prédit un peu
le risque de diabète à l'âge adulte et
ce quel que soit le poids de l'enfant
40 % des adolescents ne font aucune
activité physique hors de l'école cela
explique en partie que 15 % d'une classe
d'âge soit en excès de poids
il ya donc urgence à infléchir le
comportement des adolescents ici
l'action porte déjà ses fruits
quand j'ai commencé l'étude je ne
faisais pas de sport ça connu et je me
suis inscrit dans un tableau bastia est
bon ça va beaucoup mieux l'étude
scientifique doit durer quatre une
période suffisante pour voir l'évolution
physique
les changements de comportement de ces
adolescents et en tirer un maximum
d'enseignements